hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the new in chess classic between
magnus carlson and hikaru nakamura uh
sorry about scaring you in 4k once again
but i'm testing it out so i have to see
if everything is working properly
uh but yeah it's a really nice game and
it features everyone's favorite opening
well almost but it's
still very nice so without further ado
let's check it out uh magnus with the
white pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 by hikaru
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to c4 now we have bishop the c5
and here uh sorry wrong pawn and magnus
went for
c3 and uh now he just goes for the uh
casual joko piano main line
we have knight to f6 and now d3
we have castles by both players so
they've played this many times
probably a lot of times against each
other uh we have d5 striking in the
center and here
captures and captures and here well the
most popular option is
rook to e1 here we have just a nice
a4 instead instead of b4 but okay a4 is
on the board and while you could play a5
to stop white from further expanding on
the queen side
hikaru just spins the knight with bishop
to g4
and the the position has been reached
before but some other moves were played
like a5
but here magnus goes for h3 and it is
already as of move
9 that we have a completely new game uh
so let's see how hikaru deals with this
of course you don't want to capture
uh that's just you know developing white
for free also the knight is under attack
once the knight goes back bishop g5 all
of white's moves are incredibly natural
and uh you know just uh improve white's
position immensely so instead
uh after this h3 with bishop to h5 by
hikaru
and now all uh sorry and only now a5
grabbing more space on the queen side
we have knight back to f6 and now b4
finally b4 is on the board we have
bishop back to d6 and
now knight b to d2 uh we have a6
uh preventing y from pushing a6
and at some point and creating uh some
weaknesses on the queen side and here we
have
knight the e4 so that's a very very
strong knight and now if bishop to g5
comes
you're going to have you're going to
have problems so here he karu just
trades on e4 knight captures on e4 we
have d
captures and king to h8 now unpinning
and hikaru is now ready to play f5 and
start creating some chances on the
king's side
we have queen to d3 unpinning as the
bishop was uh
well very unpleasant here now the knight
can move and also you want to develop
your dark square bishop and connect your
rook so here we have queen the e7 hikaru
does the same he wants to connect rooks
uh and now rook to e1 uh we have knight
to d8 shifting the knight over to e6
maybe in the future you can bring it to
f4
and g3 now by magnus taking care of
those squares
we have knights to e6 and now comes
knight the h4 preparing knight to f5 and
it's uh
as you know as usual a great square for
the knight
will come with an attack on the queen
and the bishop we have rook
8 to d8 ended now knight to f5 as
planned we have queen to f6 and now
magnus uh
creates more chances and uh goes g4
so expanding on the king side making
some
his king a bit vulnerable but you know
it will be
an excellent outpost for this knight
plus the bishop has to go to g6 so you
will not
have any options of kicking away this
knight with g6 and you kind of never
want to capture this or maybe you do
uh problem is uh here magnus played
queen to f3
and it's a tough position for black what
do you play here
uh the move you kind of don't want to
play is bishop captures an f5
because even though this is a beautiful
knight and you would want to eliminate
it from there
uh you know every instinct tells you not
to touch that because if you do
uh e captures an f5 comes and it just
looks like a
tough position for for black also the b7
pawn is hanging then you know everything
can fall and then
you can just push your pawns to victory
however knight to f4 here and you kind
of don't have the option of capturing on
b7
and black uh should have a should have a
good game here or
he has to give up the lights for bishop
and then again it's it's a very nice
game
because if you go for this the knight
captures with king g2
now preparing rook to h1 the problem is
here black can sacrifice the knight and
play this move
and it's just a wonderful idea and now
if king captures the knight uh then
queen e5 threatening um uh threatening
checkmate here
and if rook to h1 there are even ideas
like queen captures and c3
you you could lose the rook here so it's
uh
uh a very nice plan or okay you could
block with the bishop bishop to e3 but
then queen captures and c for you win
back material and you know it's a
pretty crazy position but okay after
queen to f3 while this is definitely a
move
uh hikaru went for h6 instead
and okay we have king to g2 by magnus um
improving the position of the king a
little bit maybe uh leaving the option
of maybe shifting the rook over to the
king side if needed and now comes the
knight to f4 check and this move was
maybe a little bit rushed maybe a nice
slow move like rook
after e8 uh but okay it's uh it's a
rapid game so knight to f4 with
check we have bishop captures on f4 e
captures and
now magnus eliminates the bishop as well
knight captures we have phone captures
and bishop to d5
now this is very nicely protected you
have constant pressure on b7 it's a
backwards pawn so you can't really push
it
and hikaru has to defend it so rook to
d7 and now rook
a to d1 we rook to e8 and
now we reach the position from the
thumbnail where it really seems like
magnus can
sacrifice anything and here while you
could just continue
improving the position with c4 magnus
gives up the bishop with bishop captures
on c4 and this is a
quite a bold move in a rapid game where
you don't have all that much time you
know to consider stuff
uh just capturing here and giving up
your i mean it's a beautiful piece
centralized like this cuts the board in
half i mean it's a
wonderful bishop but magnus gives it up
and uh
for a very good cause or so it seems
so here uh hikaru accepts rook captures
on b7
and now e5 attacking the queen and
opening up a discovery on the rook on b7
so queen to e7 and now e captures on d6
again the queen is under attack if you
move the queen then the rook falls
uh so rook to b7 and now hikaru's point
is
uh finally seen uh magnus captures an e8
with
czech queen captures and now the rook
cannot be captured so i hope none of you
were considering this
because if the rook is captured then
bishop to e4 check wins the queen and
yes you kind of do have that rook and
you kind of do have that rook on b1 uh
but still this comes with
check after the king moves you can play
some like queen c2 attack the rook
and even if rook d5 ready to push your
pawn
i mean the the white king is too open
and you will easily you know play some
like queen b1 check king here queenie
for check win the rook
so uh you know anything can happen uh
but you know
whatever happens it will be winning of
course
so instead look to the four by magnus uh
keeping an
eye on this this e4 square so bishop d4
will no longer be an option
now comes rook to d7 and now magnus does
have a pass deep on but hikaru is up a
bishop so
what do you do here queen captures on f4
at least you
you know want some pawns and if you can
get these pawns off the board
uh you should be winning but hikaru of
course will do anything
uh everything and anything that he can
to prevent this
so queen to b8 a double attack on the
pawn so you can't really
move your queen or rook and also you're
kind of preventing c
for then the the the b for pawn falls uh
and you have to you know figure out how
to continue here
magnus played king to g3 he started by
bringing his king into the game
maybe queen to e5 was a bit more precise
here
and then you you sort of prepare uh
prepare the pawn pushes uh because then
for example maybe you can give up this
pawn then you can start pushing the
queen defends this
and if f6 then you're bringing the queen
to d5 and you know
uh maybe a slight improvement uh but
okay king to g3 was played now comes f6
and now h4 by magnus he is ready to play
g5
and bust open the position he's down a
piece but he has to attack and this d
d6 pawn is a really big bone in hikaru's
throat and he has to deal with this
constantly so here
king the g8 king to g2 magnus sort of
repeats the position a little bit bishop
to f7 and
king to g3 so here people thought that
okay magnus
doesn't really have a way of breaking
through here he's just going to repeat
king g2 king g3
and he's down on the clock he's a minute
and 30 seconds whereas hikaru has two
minutes and 30 seconds on the clock
so bishop to e6 by hikaru and now
magnus strikes with the g5 so he's uh
very much still in this game we have h
captures h captures and here we have
f captures on g5 and this was one moment
where hikaru could have seized the the
opportunity
uh with queen to b5 and this is uh clear
trouble for white now
uh the the the pawn here is defended and
you know
uh all a lot of things can go wrong if
queen captures then you can trade queens
and then you are just up a piece in an
end game and the problem is if white
captures for example on f6
then you're gonna play rook to f7 and
then it's just winning for black it
doesn't really matter what you do
you can play even c4 maybe try to get
the spawn of the board
black will just ignore you queen to h5
now threatening queen to h3
and i mean it's uh completely lost
position for magnus
but hikaru missed queen to b5 he played
f captures on g5
and this allows magnus to recollect
himself and you know
enjoy the game further and pose problems
for hikaru so queen to e5
a nice centralizing move and now bishop
to f7 the bishop is under attack so
bishop to f7
and f3 now we have king to f8 by hikaru
now comes king to f2 getting the king to
a bit of a safer square to avoid any any
future checks
so came to g8 now comes king to g3
magnus repeats once again and he carol
played king to f8 so hikaru is ready to
grab a draw here but it seems like
magnus was just uh you know
getting time because you do get
additional time for every time you make
a move
so here queen captures on g5 the game
continues
and what's the idea behind this move is
the
pawn here really hanging well it does
seem to be so hikaru grabs it
but now queen to c5 pinning this rook
so you have to defend it the rook cannot
move king to e7 and now the problem is
uh well the position is e
equal uh you know if you had like
infinite time to to analyze it of course
that's never the case in real game
but magnus is down to 30 seconds on the
clock and hikaru
has well over a minute so here we have
queen to e5 with
check king to d7 and now king to f2
magnus again
uh uh gets his king to a little bit of a
safer square and
grabs a bit more time and he asks hikaru
what do you play here because now the
rook also cannot move because the queen
would hang
so here hikaru has to play something he
has to play some like king to c6 he has
to play something like
g6 g5 those are all uh possibilities
here but hikaru played
the one move that he shouldn't have
played he played queen to f8
probably with the idea of just uh
shifting you know the queens here and
also to keep an eye on the g7 pawn
but now the game is losing for hikaru so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find
the only winning move for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not
doing anything weird like i don't know
something like pushing the pawns
although that's a very nice idea if you
were thinking about that
uh and for those of you who found queen
to f5 check then congratulations this
is the correct idea and now the problem
is next he
removes the king as one would in uh you
know when uh
being in check and now comes queen to c5
with
check you don't have to do this magnus
only repeats it once to gain more time
on the clock uh because you know
why not so king d7 now magnus repeats
queen to f5 check king to c6 and only
now rook captures on d6 this was the
point you didn't of course
in your own calculations you were not
winning more time
and now the problem is you cannot play
king captures on d6 to save the bishop
because queen c5 check and then you lose
the queen whatever
wherever the king moves you just lose
the queen so here queen captures was
played and now magnus plays queen
captures and f7 he wins his bishop
back and now he's simply up to pawn so
can hikaru hold his
hold this we know that the absolutely
most complicated end games in chess
are queens and games uh and maybe hikaru
can hold this so he starts by delivering
checks queen d2 check
king g3 and queen captures on c3 now
magnus is only up one pawn
queen to e8 to check king to c7 and now
queen to e4 a nice centralizing move
keeping an eye on everything
and now magnus needs to figure out how
to win this because it is a rapid game
you don't have all that much time
so king to b6 now comes king g4 he has
to bring his king into the game we have
queen to a1
now trying to get some checks in from
behind but now queen to d3 with
check king to e7 and now queen to e3
with
check you could go after the pawn on a6
but if you grab this then queen to d
for check and you have to suffer you
know
checks to infinity and it's a question
if you will ever get out
so magnus uh uh does not rush grabbing
this pawn queen e3 check
king to f7 now queen to c5 just
controlling all of the squares that
hikaru can use
to deliver checks uh so here we have
king to g8 and now
king to f4 and now hikaru was already
down to a few seconds here
he of course doesn't get increment but
it's still very hard to play this
so queen d1 now comes king to e5 and now
magnus wants to start bringing his king
into the game win the pawn with the king
and then start pushing the queen side
wants to victory
so king h7 we have queen to d5 and now
queen to a4 going after this pawn queen
e4
check king to h8 and now king the d6
everything is nicely protected and there
are no good checks that you can give
so queen b5 uh and now king to c7 so
magnus is getting closer
closer and closer we have king to g8 and
now again
a few checks to grab more more time on
the clock king h7
queen to d6 now so now you can even
start pushing this spawn
we have queen to e2 and then now comes
f4
we have queen back to b5 and now queen
to c5
offering a queen trade but basically
what you're doing is uh king the queen
away
from controlling the b file so the king
can go here and grab this
a6 pawn so queen to f1 keeping an eye on
the pawn but now
queen h5 check again a few checks queen
d5 chair king h7
now queen e4 check king to h8 and now
king to b6 now you're ready to attack
the pawn once again with the queen
and win it so here queen to b5 check
king to a7 and now queen back to f1
uh putting pressure on this pawn so if
white goes over to
grab the a6 pawn then you will at least
grab the f4 pawn
so queen to e8 check king h7 queen to h5
check king the g8 queen d5 check again
magnus uses this triangle to win
more time on the clock king h7 and now
f5
so hikaru again doesn't really have a
good move he has to play something
attacks the pawn
queen d6 now defends the pawn and offers
this pawn but he is now ready to grab
the a6 pawn there's nothing better for
hikaru so he grabs the pawn
magnus grabs this one but with the king
the queen is much better
kept here centralized and now g5
that's not a g5 we have g5 and
now b5 now both hikaru and magnus start
pushing their pawns but not the g4 right
away
uh first queen to f1 pinning this pawn
so magnus now
has to waste the move with the king so
king b6 and now
queen f2 check we have queen c5 and now
uh
queen to f6 with check king a7
ready to push the pawns and now queen to
f7 check king a6
and now hikaru pushes the g pawn we have
b6
g3 b7 and now comes queen to f1
with check we have king the a7 and here
he carl plays the incredible queen to f2
and magnus could not believe that
hikaru found this and he was in shock uh
but there is a solution to this so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this solution
that magnus may or may not have found
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not capturing
the queen
you could do that and you might win but
you know you're in
one one hell of a game because if you go
for this captures and captures and then
we both queen then yes
we both queen you still have a past pawn
but you're gonna you know have to
go through a million checks before you
can actually win this game
but if you found the move magnus played
and that is queen to b6
then congratulations you are a true
master of the end game
and now there's a problem of course
because you can't continue pushing the
pawn
because the queen hangs and if you trade
here captures
then a captures here you voluntarily
double your pawns because
after g2 b8 queen now this
g1 queen does not come with check your
pawn here is protecting you and now of
course it will you will centralize your
queen and
start pushing this pawn it's much much
faster and much much easier if black
doesn't queen with
check so instead after this queen to b6
we have queen to f7 by hikaru now comes
queen to b1
with check king h6 now comes queen to e4
guarding the g2 square so hikaru can
start pushing
queen g7 are ready to push and also
pinning this pawn but now
it was also in this position that hikaru
nakamura resigned to the game
as there really is nothing more to be
done here uh just to give you an example
after magnus plays something like king
288 that's it uh
while both players will get queens and
we might get
we might even get four queens on the
board uh it does not help you cover
because he is in a meeting that it's
actually
a force made in four just queen to h4
with check
king g6 now comes queen to d6 with check
and there's nothing you cannot block
because the both queens cover the f6
square
so king to f7 something like this queen
to d5 check
now all of these uh lines are are
covered and now it doesn't matter
wherever you go
uh it's made in one for example king to
king to f8 you're just going to get
queen to d8 with checkmate there's no no
square for you all of this is covered
and that's it so of course hikaru knew
this and after this uh
queen uh sorry and after this queen to
g7 move he resigned the game
so in the first match magnus takes the
lead in the third game so now it's
magnus leading the match by one point
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
simon melissa
andreas moss uh marbonic uh michael
higgins uh and uh
seagrave gallery for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
checking up on your one of suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day